mueve el punto anaranjado a tres medios
en la recta numérica aquí tenemos la
recta numérica aquí está en cero aquí
está el 3 así que este punto es el 1 y
este punto es el 2 para mover el punto
lo podemos hacer de dos maneras una
manera es tratar de pasar esta fracción
impropia al número mixto el 2 cabe una
vez en tres entonces tres medios es lo
mismo que un entero un medio entonces
este punto quedaría en un entero un
medio o también lo podemos hacer de esta
manera vámonos por mitades aquí tenemos
un medio dos medios que es un entero
tres medios y listo
mueve el punto anaranjado a diecisiete
sextos en la recta numérica
esto igual lo podemos hacer de dos
maneras la primera es observando que 17
sextos es lo mismo que dos enteros cinco
sextos entonces el punto lo movemos a
dos enteros y luego uno dos tres cuatro
cinco sextos
la otra forma de hacerlo es contando los
17 sextos
entonces tenemos un sexto dos sextos
tres sextos cuatro sextos cinco sextos
seis sextos y esto es un entero
sigamos siete sextos ocho sextos nueve
sextos diez sextos once sextos doce
sextos que es lo mismo que dos enteros
sigamos trece sextos catorce sextos
quince sextos dieciséis sextos y
diecisiete sextos y listo ya movimos el
punto a donde debe de estar hagamos uno
más me estoy divirtiendo mueve el punto
anaranjado a nueve quintos en la recta
numérica
entonces esto sería un quinto dos
quintos tres quintos cuatro quintos
cinco quintos seis puntos siete quintos
ocho quintos nueve quintos